-Have a seat.
We have lots to talk about.
-The last time I was here,
we were in the other studio,
and this is just so amazing
to see everyone.
-It's the greatest, yeah.
-[ Cheers and applause ]
Thanks so much for being here.
-Oh, my God. I love you.
-I love you so much.
What do we have to get into?
We have so much to get into.
I'm going to start
with Halloween
because I think I'm going to
see you this weekend.
-Yeah.
-The kids are gonna hook up.
-The producers were like,
you know,
"What are you gonna be doing
for Halloween?"
I was like, "Ironically,
I'll be with Jimmy."
-We're actually hanging out.
-Yeah.
-Are they carving pumpkins?
-We've been carving pumpkins.
We got hu-- This guy, weirdly,
got us a pumpkin
at this pumpkin patch,
and we couldn't carry it.
-Wait. Sorry.
You were at a pumpkin patch.
-Yes!
-We're not surprised about that.
But then a guy --
-I love the patch!
-A guy got you a pumpkin?
-Weirdly, I had
this whole life lesson
with Olive about letting it go.
We couldn't carry it.
You've got to, like,
make your peace with it.
And she really did.
And then we got
to the checkout stand,
and this guy
wheelbarrowed it up,
and we both started crying.
[ Laughter ]
-Because you already said
goodbye to that pumpkin.
-And she had, like,
learned to love and let go.
And then I started crying,
and then we were like,
"It's a Halloween miracle!"
-Miracle! Oh, my God.
A Halloween miracle. Please.
-And then he had this beautiful,
like, Jesus around his neck.
And I started having,
like, a religious moment.
-Oh, my God.
-I did.
-You thought it was Jesus
bringing you a pumpkin?
-Yes! And I was like,
"Thank you so much."
Then here is the weirdest thing.
I was like -- First of all --
Then also as a parent,
I started spiraling.
I wanted to be like, "I don't
know. This isn't the lesson.
This isn't the lesson!"
The lesson was let it go!
Not you get it!
-You get anything you want.
-So I'm, like, paralyzed
as a parent,
like, not knowing how to handle
this situation.
I want to make it okay for him.
I want her to learn her lesson.
I -- And then also I'm like,
"I got to pay you back.
I want to say thank you."
He's like, "No."
And I'm like,
"Can I get your phone number
just so I can, you know,
pay you back and say..."
"No." He wanted nothing.
-Wow.
And then he just walked on water
away from you guys.
-Yes! 100%!
-That was really --
It was him or Peter Sellers.
[ Laughter ]
-Chauncey Gardiner!
-Chauncey Gardiner.
I knew you'd like that one.
-The Halloween miracle.
So you got a giant pumpkin.
-Yes!
-I wanna see this.
-And then we carved it,
and we saved all the seeds,
and we had this whole ceremony.
And I said, you know,
we can't send him a picture,
and he didn't want anything
in return,
because, you know,
he's a saint.
Literally.
-He's not real, yeah.
Of course.
-If he ever hears this story,
like, you really made me
and my daughter cry.
And the pumpkin's beautiful.
And it did make us
believe in miracles.
-Yeah. Why not?
"The Pumpkin Miracle."
I love that.
Look for it next holiday season.
-Coming to Hallmark Channel.
-Coming to Hallmark.
I want to talk
about your cookbook.
I know how hard you worked
on this thing.
I know how much you love
cookbooks.
You have a cookbook collection.
We both have read cookbooks
together.
-You and I are big --
-I'm obsessed with cookbooks.
-Ever since -- I mean,
we've known each other
for a very long time.
And you have always felt like
chefs are rock stars,
and I feel the same way.
Like, I'm very intimidated,
blown away by, and, like,
[ Gasps ]
"That chef just walked in!"
-Yeah. I love it. I think
they're almost like athletes.
-Yes!
-You come here and you go like,
"Oh, I can throw a football."
And you go, "Not really.
Drew Brees can throw
a football."
And then you've got a chef
who comes on.
You go like,
"I know how to make pasta."
You go, "No, you don't have to
make --" It's just amazing.
-Who are your heroes?
And a lot of mine --
And I also think the food
industry is so nurturing,
and they take care of each other
and they take care of us
and there are memories to be
made and food is a privilege.
So it's just been something
that's been at the forefront
of my universe.
But I didn't want to
pretend to be the,
you know, me and my kitchen.
I'm so not that guy.
-No.
-So I put 300 of
my personal photographs.
I wrote the whole thing
with Pilar.
It's very personal.
-Yeah.
-And I took that picture.
And I was like, "How can I make
a book that isn't going to
give me imposter syndrome
into a world
I'm so humble
and freaked out about?"
And so it's very personal, which
made it take so much more work.
-Yeah, because you were like,
"I'm not just going to throw
something out there just to
have a cookbook out there."
-Writing hundreds of pages.
There is -- By the way,
there's me at the patch.
-Wait. This can't be --
This is not this recent.
-That's a different pumpkin.
-What?!
-Yeah.
That's the year before.
-Did a man give this to you?
-No. And guess what.
That pumpkin did not come home
with me.
He stayed there in the patch.
-So you just gave it love
and then let it be.
-Yeah.
-That's another --
-'Cause who is carrying that?
There's no one to help you.
It's you and a wheelbarrow.
Unless the saint comes along.
-Yeah, yeah,
a miracle comes along.
-And I love food,
and I love cooking, and I --
-I did make this one,
by the way, the pasta.
The creamy, like, lemon
and the peas.
-It's the best. It's a
[Italian accent] mascarpone.
[ Normal voice ]
This is my favorite cheese
to cook pasta with,
and I love adding the --
-And they're also the band
tonight.
Mascarpone is here.
[ Laughter ]
-By the way, talk about,
like, I got shy.
I saw them in the hallway
and I was like, "Oh, wow.
They look really cool."
[ Laughter ]
-They were saying
the same about you.
-Oh, no.
-I think you're doing
such a great job on the show.
You know I watch.
I'm a religious -- I watch
your show every morning.
-I don't know what I would
have done without you
because we were launching
in a pandemic.
You were such
a brother and guider.
-I go, "What other person
would launch a show
during a pandemic
except for you?"
But you did it.
-And we did this book
in a pandemic.
And I think this is just
a great time to not pretend,
but peel back the layers
and be more ourselves than ever
and celebrate our little,
beautiful, weird individuality
and cheer each other on and
share our lives and experiences.
I was so optimistic
in the pandemic
when people were cooking
the same things together online
to have some form of community.
That gave me a sign, like,
maybe I should proceed
with this project and create
an intimacy and not a veneer.
-Yeah. It is very you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Rebel Homemaker."
"Rebel Homemaker"
is the name of the book.
November 2nd it is out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And always watch
"The Drew Barrymore Show"
on every single morning.